[Applause]
[Music]
yes
i'm doing the try not to life challenge
i just failed it
but if i laugh i have to donate a
thousand what's on in dollars
to a random charity let's freaking do
this
a scene from an indian tv show bathroom
scrubbers
my man use bathroom scrubbers
no no no no
all right fine one laugh what should i
donate to should i donate to random
streamers
i never actually done they i said i was
gonna donate to charity but here i am
all right who has the least amount of
viewers playing this game
i think it was brown uh yeah i did my
intro when i was
when i was happy all right
that's awesome i did it my first twitch
donation
there it is that was so worth it
not seeing it right away and thanks for
the five minutes
what uh pewdiepie has donated 69 dollars
are you serious all right uh
that's what it says
that's my first donation is
[Laughter]
hey made me laugh that's great all right
next one
a picture of my brother in p class today
are you serious all right that didn't
count because
uh it has to be a video that's right
yeah that's why this gorilla mom is
dealing with her eldest son's jealousy
of the baby and she's done with this
what no
no they just spit on out
god damn it it caught me off guard fine
just
chatting recommended for me huh thank
you twitch
why is everyone in sweden just so we're
clear i don't know who the [ __ ] this
people are
okay uh fall guys does anyone play fall
games anymore
see when i go bright it just goes in my
face it might as well
just have a light all right we'll give
her a
so i challenge i don't really hate it
hello
hello good morning how are you
oh there it is oh god damn it i keep
thank you for that
10x if you win ah there's no way i'm
gonna win there's no way i'm gonna win
99 epic i'm not gonna win i'm just not
gonna win
well you already lost clearly
from now on i will not laugh this is a
waste of money
ready for first pandemic halloween what
are they gonna do suck the candy up
oh god is halloween cancelled i didn't
even think of that oh no
well i didn't laugh so i don't have to
donate before you're mean to someone
online remember they're human too
so you got to be tactical aim for the
heart hit their insecurities find
fragile spots that's right there
that was a chuckle that was a chuckle i
refused to
donate for that seriously with my
mattress the truck is packed tight
nothing will move
no don't and done oh god
i feel like i could laugh but also i'm
in a mood where i no i cannot laugh i
will not laugh
that is just sexy were really excited to
use lime
from our f lime tree for the first time
oh that was a chuckle chuckle do not can
chuckle do not i'm not
i'm not donating unless it's a proper
laugh
i repeat there are people inside the
building it seems a brave man is going
in
i think he just wanted to die oh god
stop this is chuckling
i am chuckling all right video let's go
oh mega lol is that what you could say
on twitch
pog champ uh close today due to gestures
broadly
at everything please take care and we'll
be back soon what
hey what does this button do really
don't touch that really no
screw it i always wondered what that
button does now i know holy [ __ ]
god damn it fine beating minecraft is
still that's that sounds pretty
interesting
please donate if you will like
support the channel all right what is
this goal
a hundred i'm not gonna do that it feels
weird donating 69 to a child
right i even felt weird about the last
one we'll do 69 68.
oh he hurt he found out i'm here paypal
think this is weird behavior i usually
don't spend this much money
[Laughter]
there it is boom did someone just follow
me
thank you whoever followed or anything i
didn't follow
sick uh bs uh price
thank you he thanked someone else are
you serious
he thought he got a follow-up
don't just turn around come on
i donated 70 of your goal
i'm gonna keep a stream in the
background in case you realize pass
by a math book example today oh that's
funny
i will say that it's funny instead of
laughing yes i'm one of those people to
it
to to win this challenge that is funny
cocomelon be like i [ __ ] know it
walking but not walking
pushing but not pushing enough for this
nonsense
best time ever to get braces yeah that
is funny
that is funny anyone that's watching um
yeah i'm watching we are not
professional speedrunners oh really
why'd you leave the game all right i'm
leaving this
what a waste of money huh i lost i lost
wait a minute i'm not supposed to lose
let me see the script
literally being held by a threat god
no i did not laugh i'm sick of this how
dare you take a photo of woman's butt
that's disgusting
i'm not laughing today yo what up dogs
paul rudd here actor and certified young
person a few days ago
i was talking on the iphone with my
homie governor cuomo and he's just going
off about how us millennials need to
wear masks
because get this apparently a lot of
covid is transmitted by us
millennials no cap so qualms asked me
he's like paul
you gotta help what are you like 26 and
i didn't correct him
so fam let's real talk masks
they're totally beast so slide that into
your dms and twitch it
all right i i like polaroid but i'm not
sitting through this that's not
happening
optimus the glass is half full pestimus
the glass is half empty
2020 that's p isn't it that's gamer girl
pp right there
i will not laugh i use cannabis all for
oh god i'm gonna laugh
the medical pro i accidentally dropped
some to the
[Music]
is that funny i can't even
he's okay
all right fine god damn it i gotta
donate
gotta donate
look who's live i knew it
that's working in front who's pewdiepie
this isn't pewdiepie
find out who you really are oh also by
the way here you go that's i'm not even
acknowledging this i'm joke because it's
too much money clicking this button
[Music]
you have that ready for big donations
[Laughter]
[Music]
well well done
hey all right
[Music]
i think you aimed for 69
and you got 68.99
all right no more laughing from now on
if i laugh one more time i have to
donate
680.99
that's a wolf that's a wolf right there
oh oh god now it's pain
it's pr pain
take your nose you can't do that yes i
just did
no you can't i need that back
no
that's funny please
[Music]
why would you do that because it's funny
you can't just no
no all right i get two lives
all right i get two lives it's six x six
or eighty
treat me like a car i have the same
right to use the road as you
nah
yo what how
what
i'm so confused
is that sweden
oh my god it annoys me so much oh he's
pulling a string
right no what is he doing what's the
trick i don't know i don't care
i actually don't care i only check the
news once a week now
still okay yeah
i get three strikes three how do i get a
boy to like me treat him like a king
hey that's funny
maybe do it in a downhill your dumb
asses that does not count
my daughter got an etch-a-sketch today
for her eighth birthday she drew a cat
puking
oh god no no i that ain't it
that ain't me no no
no fine you are correct
i will donate next time if you smash
like on this video and subscribe and
i'll see you in the next episode
of you laugh you donate see ya
bye bye remember to subscribe we're
almost at 107 million that would be epic
thank you
ah